hi my name is aubry plaza and i am here
with buzzfeed to read your thirst tweets
i'm just gonna say right now that i
think probably 90 of these are gonna be
people telling me they want me to run
them over with a car or like stomp on
their face or something let's do it
if aubrey plaza actually reads thirst
tweets i will be burying myself alive
um i'm doing it so i hope that you're
gonna bury yourself alive miss aubry
plaza are you free on thursday because i
am free on thursday so if you want to go
out on thursday when i am free that
would be great because i am free on
thursday and thursdays when i'm free i
i'm not free on thursday i'm free on
never day
i wish aubry plaza and matthew gray
goobler were my birth parents actually
no i wish i was in a throuple with them
i think you
need to decide if you want to be in a
throuple with your parents and that's
something that you should talk to your
therapist about and i don't know who
matthew gray gubler is i've never heard
of that person in my life aubry plaza
reading thirst tweets let's bring back
her drinking milk trowel her nose
because that was
h-o-t all capitals hot
exclamation point exclamation point
exclamation point first of all i was
snorting milk through my nose i wasn't
drinking it through my nose and i don't
have any milk right now so i'm not gonna
do that aubrey plaza if you are
listening please let me take you out on
a date i am a good company i swear i'm
not a sweaty person i will let you be
mean
oh that's enticing that's
really um
yeah perfect threesome question mark me
aubry plaza and a tub of peanut butter
that makes
me feel weird i'm sorry for being
thirsty on maine i'm just a huge simp
for aubry plaza what is simp why does
everyone say simp what is this i don't
understand simp is the grossest word
i've ever heard though i don't like
saying it or reading it like this tweet
if you would suck aubry plaza's big toe
and if you don't like this tweet let me
know so i can block you that i like that
is just nasty and
i'm into it
i'm watching anger goes west and i just
want to say that i would like both aubry
plaza and elizabeth olsen to curb stomp
me okay this is what i'm talking about i
knew that most of these tweets were
gonna be about stomping on your face or
crushing you with high heels or running
you over with a car aubry plaza is so
daddy she can fix all my daddy issues i
don't know that's just ironic i feel
like i have daddy issues and i feel like
i want my daddy to
fix my daddy issues but i'll be your
daddy i'd put myself on a spit roast for
aubry plaza
thank you so much chris and stewart and
aubrey plaza step on my face challenge
what is it about stepping on your face
people twitter why do you want me to
step on your face how did we get to this
point in
the world aubry plaza hot sex gorgeous
good acting hilarious funny amazing
person charitable busy with the two s's
bussy bussy amazing sexy pretty cute
emily the criminal that was a bot i
think that was a bot and that was not a
real person i would walk into traffic
for aubry plaza i would sacrifice my
firstborn for aubry plaza i would let
aubry plaza kill me if she wanted to
god i would do anything just to smell
her hair
aubry plaza is a goddess and no other
human woman will ever live up to her
standard again thank you so much the
feminine urge to get railed by aubry
plaza
get railed why do you guys want me to
rail you because i could
aubrey plaza could choke me to death and
i'd still be like
nice the violence in these tweets i have
nightmares about this people want me to
be mean to them i don't what did i do to
deserve this i'm a nice person i know
everyone has a crush on aubry plaza but
i would actually let her stab me again
with the stabbing and the stomping and
the chomping it's like a weird thing
where it's like i hear i hear this so
much that i don't i want to stab you i
want to stab you and i would i would let
jesus
[ __ ]
sick you were all sick sick little
babies and you all need to be stabbed
and stomped on i would let aubry plaza
poke my eyeball out with a fork and step
on my throat with boots with nails on
them and if it pleased her well you know
what it does please me
petition for aubry plaza to plow me i
support your petition and i don't know
if i if we're gonna get there but if we
do you're welcome aubry plaza i am
simply just a hole for you
i
and i'm simply just a
i'm a person i'm a human being what do
you want me to do to your holes be more
specific what do you want me to do to
your holes twitter because i will anyway
i'm looking forward to more
people wanting me to stab them
and um throw them into oncoming traffic
i asked for this and
i deserve this check out my movie emily
the criminal it's coming out in theaters
you can sit in the theater and imagine
me stabbing your holes and railing you
with my goddamn talent
sick
the thing is that i want to be dominated
that's the thing that y'all are missing
is that i want to be slapped around and
choked and
stabbed but
whatever
[Music]